ik Ben het met u
het is goed nieuws dat meer partijen nu inzien dat
het feit dat zoveel mensen in Nederland de rekening
niet meer kunnen betalen
terwijl tegelijkertijd
de winsten van grote bedrijven afgelopen jaar bijna 400
miljard waren
het aantal miljardairs in Nederland groeit
dat dat niet kan
dus ik Ben daar heel blij mee
mijn zorg is dat het niet automatisch goed komt
en dat het misschien
toch ook wel hele mooie verkiezingsbeloftes
blijken te zijn
ik zit hier aan tafel met
2 heren waarvan ik even HEB gekeken bij 3 hele concrete
dingen als het gaat over bestaanszekerheid
hoe hebben zij gestemd op onze moties
dan gaat het over de zorg dichtbij
ziekenhuizen openhouden
helaas CDA en D66 tegen
dan gaat het over de huren bevriezen
toch wel prettig in deze tijd van hoge kosten
D66 heeft het zelfs in de stemwijzer staan maar helaas
onze motie werd weggestemd
en dan gaat het over het verhogen van het minimumloon
naar 16 euro
als je echt wat wilt doen aan bestaanszekerheid
helaas CDA en D66 tegen
ja ik denk
grote sp is de beste garantie
dat het dan ook echt goed komt
dat er echt wat gaat veranderen